can I see all those in favor of schools
compensate one and all those against
I think that's carried and with that
Labour adopted perhaps one of the more
controversial policies in its history
the effective abolition of private
schools something unthinkable under
Blair not even policy under its most
radical governments of the nineteen
forty and the language employed was more
radical still well it means that we can
look at that within our social justice
Commission cuz we want a fair system
that's what it means it means that no
longer can taxpayers money go into
private institutions that they squirrel
away to help the 7% of our country do
well when they're at the expense of
everybody else this was a policy which
got them excited here and yet another
day of endless bricks of contortions it
was pure red meat a reason for the
activists to turn out which ahead of an
expected election campaign really
matters I went to private school myself
I don't think it is a fair way of doing
education to abolish certain doesn't
necessarily mean that it'll be better
for everybody else because they were
abolished but the counter-reaction
a mere echo of what will surely be to
come with Swift it's a great idea as
long as standards are good
the problem is what independent schools
bring at the moment to the overall
educational system is a whole lot of
specialism and capacity that might not
be available otherwise only 7% of
children go to private schools despite
that this is a policy which has the
potential to dominate an election
champagne it will surely solidify the
Tory vote in the Home Counties perhaps
those who had been toying with voting
Lib Dem but for labour they hope it will
act as a signal of a wider conflict in
an age of populism and a populace of
brexit and of Trump labour so often
appearing buffeted around accuse of
embodying the interests of the liberal
metropolitan elite this is their way of
combating that of drawing a line in the
sand of them and us that they represent
the interests of ordinary people it is
frankly a thought of populism with which
they're comfortable the sunset over
Brighton and surely over any Labour
hopes of advanced in middling into but
perhaps they abandon that long ago
anyway this is a policy about
consolidation of their vote not
expanding it and in that in British
politics right now they're hardly alone
Lewis could all Sky News Brighton